I want to talk about the movie Trishna
this is a it's a really beautiful film
and in the movie you get to break out
some dance moves I do it's nice it's my
first film I danced and I done sent this
one and there's another one that I've
danced and I guess it should be in my
contract she will only be part of your
film if she gets to dance right so no
matter what will you make now you'll
break into dance the next one actually I
play a dancer so there you go another
dance right do you do and you enjoy
dancing you like it I do I do what about
you I like it but no one else likes me
doing it no that's not true it is true
yeah no I move around I'm an awkward no
no that was me actually in pain physical
pain no one likes you no I'm not I'm
very gangly Andy you got me up on this
I'm not gonna sit here and insult you
I'm gonna wait until the cameras are off
and then I'm gonna tell her that you're
a terrible dancer see listen if you ever
want to do a Bollywood film if you're
ever interested in that all you have to
do is work on those hips really because
that is is that the key to the the
Indian form of dances it's only it's
really in the hips it's really for those
people who know Bollywood films and
Bollywood dancing it's really in the
hips and if you can just move them then
you're good you're good to go
yeah see mine really don't move I come
from an Irish Catholic culture where
nothing between my neck and my kneecaps
moves at all what do you do do an
amazing footwork Don said what's that
what's that what's that what's that
what's that called that's just a lot of
caffeine yeah the name of the the form
of does that's that ooo the step dancing
at the Irish game yeah that's for Irish
girls mostly I so I qualified
three pretty girls yeah we have we have
a clip from trishna and maybe you could
tell us a little bit about it this is
it's a love story it is it's a tragic
love story and it's actually the remake
Indian version of Tess of the
d'Urbervilles which is a Thomas Hardy in
19th century novel and the scene is the
scene with in the film Alec teaches
tests to whistles and this Jay teaches
trishna the whistle and he's referencing
a classic American scene with Humphrey
Bogart would say where the split from
trishna what dad likes it when you
whistle for them you know how to whistle
don't you you just put your lips
together and blow
put your lips like this
[Music]
yeah
see easy where'd you say you found it
where did you come in beautiful